we just introduced you to tiny home
mogul michelle boyle
there she is my new hero and after
getting divorced
and becoming an empty nester she
realized she needed to downsize her
lifestyle to supersize her quality of
life
and michelle has built and designed a
whole village of tiny homes
specifically in design what do you find
are your biggest challenges
um the design challenge for me was
incorporating spaces for my
massive collection of shoes so
they're not just stairs they're also
shoe storage
there's a litter box tucked in uh really
the challenges are all about taking
advantage of the tiny space that you
have available for the stuff that you
love big
okay so you're currently working on your
latest tiny home
and um if you don't mind uh we wanted to
take the design work off your plate and
put it onto ours
and it's our first tiny home ever for a
design
by drew check this out i'm so excited to
show you
[Applause]
all right michelle i can't
wait to hear what you the boss lady has
to say
about this so i wanted to bring some of
uh the company i have called uh flower
home
into this and uh the reason why is
because it had some really nice
neutral botanicals and i just wanted to
add as much
sort of outdoor feeling
onto the inside so i wanted to pick a
neutral botanical that would kind of go
with everything
and then we did these really lovely
cylindrical sconces
um on the vanity table we got you this
vanity
and um this is all flower home these
prints and this wallpaper and the truth
is
paint wasn't enough you needed a pattern
somewhere but a nice
light pattern then
one of the things that i really wanted
to do since you have this
bunk bed situation is first of all we're
adults
so i'm like let's get a bunk bed that
doesn't feel like it's for kids
so we thought about train beds
and usually train beds have a really
nice curtain
and we only did it on the bottom so that
if someone's spending the night
then they feel like they have a little
privacy
shield and then i threw in some flower
home and like a really
nice sort of gray-taupey
linen bedding that i thought wouldn't
fight
the other patterns i put a little side
table here
with some flowers and then up here
as well as down here i put a really
beautiful sconce
the reason i chose this scone is because
we always talk about the glow light
and even these sconces over here as well
as the cylindrical lights over here
you're going to see
all of these in the same room so they
have got to speak to each other in
hardware but you also want to maximize
even though there's now several light
sources if they
glow rather than point you're going to
have a
warmer room then we brought i gave you
some beautiful stuff for your kitchen
because these um come you know they're
out on your counter
and i wanted it to look really pretty i
did some flower home dishes
and we did a cute little chalkboard for
you here that says welcome home
that's right michelle welcome home and
then
for this eating nook i really thought
about
keeping the backs of the stools very low
and the color should match so that
it flows i really thought a lot about
the color scheme
so that the whole room could look
uniform together
but then also have very designated areas
kitchen
eating area bedroom but they're not
fighting each other
so you really want something soft and
cohesive michelle
thoughts oh gosh
you nailed it oh gosh
so scared i do
you nailed it and so it's all about
creating a cohesive
space and separating the functionality
with color and design
but at the same time it doesn't feel
like overbearing or too much
i think you nailed it your ceilings need
a little bit a little bit higher
a couple more windows and we're there
okay
good well i'm glad you approved because
i really approve
of the mini mogul that you have become
and the empire that you are building
because not only has it changed your
life but it's changing other people's
lives
so thank you michelle now we're going to
send all of this to oregon
write to you everything in this room
everything are you kidding me yes of
course
oh my gosh that's so amazing
well please come back and show us what
you've done and how you execute it we
have much to learn from you michelle
thank you so much